cpac is the conservative political
action conference
it culminated yesterday in an erratic
and delusional crescendo
with former president donald trump's
first speech since leaving office on
january 20th
the speech started of course 70 minutes
late for no
good reason endlessly delayed and was
rife with all of the things we would
expect from donald trump lies about what
he did
lies about what he didn't do lies about
what joe biden has done so far
lies about what joe biden has not done
so far lies about immigrants
lies about covid lies about the economy
a victimhood complex that would be uh uh
worthy of a few decades of
psychoanalysis and of course yes
false claims that donald trump actually
won the election
the speech was expected to be a fidel
castro like two hours or more
in the end it was about 90 minutes trump
appeared to sort of skip
a bunch of the end when he and the crowd
seemed increasingly bored by the things
that he was saying
the crowd was also bored and silent
during many parts of the speech they
were most riled up and this tells you a
lot about
the state of the republican party the
crowd most titillated
when trump called kovid the china virus
they erupted with a standing ovation
when trump claimed he won the election
the crowd went nuts
and when trump talked about the new
wedge issue of
transgender women in sports the crowd
also gave a standing ovation those were
the things that were most
interesting to the crowd i can't
possibly cover the whole speech
i want to touch on some key moments
donald trump opened the speech
by claiming that his presidency was the
most successful in history
despite losing and becoming one of of
only 10 one-term presidents
trump says his was the most successful
to so many wonderful friends
conservatives and fellow citizens in
this room and all across our country i
stand before
you today to declare that the incredible
journey we've begun
together we went through a journey like
nobody else there's
never been a journey like it there's
never been a journey so successful
we began it together four years ago
interesting to take a presidency
with no accomplishments a globally
humiliating failure on the pandemic and
a huge electoral loss
and call it the most successful but okay
the crowd i guess liked it
most importantly donald trump making it
clear he is not starting a new party
and the the president the former
president rightly identifies
that starting a new party would make
republicans lose for a long time
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party it's going
to unite and be stronger than ever
before i am not starting a new party
that was fake news fake news no
wouldn't that be brilliant let's start a
new party and let's divide our vote
so that you can never win no we're not
interested in that so trump's analysis
there
is correct uh the the best assessment is
the reports were accurate at the time
trump was thinking of starting a new
party
but he was talked out a bit for this
reason that it would fracture the right
and they wouldn't win for a very long
time which was also
our assessment of that idea as usual
donald trump
cites out of context and apparently
meaningless polling numbers about how
popular he is he can't get away from
this take a listen
mr mclaughlin just gave me numbers that
nobody's ever heard of before more
popular than anybody that's all of us
it's all of us
those are great numbers and i want to
thank you very much those are incredible
numbers i came here and he were giving
me 95
97 92
[Applause]
no one has ever been more popular than
trump
according to mr mclaughlin the reality
is trump
is the only president never to pull 50
approval throughout his presidency and
the only president to leave office
with an approval so low it was 29
percent approval
when donald trump left office and then
after all of these lies donald trump
pulls out the big lie
that he won and maybe he will even win
the presidential election a third time
alluding to maybe running in 2024
and the crowd goes nuts but who knows
who knows i may even decide
to beat them for a third time okay
importantly though donald trump did not
announce his 2024 candidacy it was
rumored he might at yesterday's speech
he said he might run and that we'll see
we'll get to that later trump again
claims that
if the election had been fair he would
have won i said it
had we had a fair election
the results would have been much
different and then donald trump launched
another brutal but completely ignorant
attack on
wind power you knew he would do it how
bad is wind power so i talk about it all
the time at cpac right we went to
cpac remember last i said we're going to
watch the president
well alice uh the wind isn't blowing i
don't believe we'll have any electricity
remember we would
we would kid but i wasn't actually
kidding it's
such an import it's such an expensive
form of energy
it's so bad for the environment it kills
the
birds it destroys the landscapes and
remember
these are structural columns with fans
on them they wear out
and when they wear out all over the
country you see them nobody takes them
down they're rotting they're rusting
how this is environmentally good for our
country and it costs
many many times more than natural gas
which is clean it costs many more
and can fuel our great factories wind
can't do that and
clearly donald trump understanding
nothing about
wind power that's the takeaway uh wind
power is bad for the environment and he
says it kills birds
it's not bad for the environment wind
turbines
do kill some birds but fossil fuel power
kills way more animals and trump doesn't
seem to care about that
at all it's merely a talking point that
does well with the uninformed crowd
then donald trump again claims he won
the election twice and the crowd just
loves it famous for the rest of their
lives
we won the election twice i mean you
know think about it
the task for our movement and then
donald
trump introducing the new wedge issue
gets a standing ovation the issue is
trans women in sports now i think it's
crazy i think it's just crazy what's
happening
we must protect the integrity of women's
sports so important
after
[Applause]
[Music]
he then went into a mildly transphobic
rant
about that issue and the crowd
re-energized by that now this next part
is really important
donald trump is not starting his own
party i mentioned that earlier
but he's going out hard against
republicans
he doesn't like republicans he sees as
not loyal enough to him
and he calls out a long list of
republican senators and members of the
house here
democrats don't have grandstanders like
mitt romney
little ben sass richard burr bill
cassidy susan collins
lisa murkowski pat toomey
[Applause]
and in the house tom rice
south carolina adam kinzinger
dan newhouse anthony gonzalez that's
another beauty
fred upton jamie herrera butler
peter meyer john catko david
valadeo and of course the warmonger
a person that loves seeing our troops
fighting
liz cheney how about that
[Applause]
so while donald trump did recognize that
starting his own party would be bad for
the right
he apparently doesn't think that
attacking other republicans will be bad
for the right
maybe he's right i don't know i guess
we'll have to wait and see what impact
that has but trump going
very hard against other republicans
and then trump plugging a website
where you can give money he now says
he's committed to helping republicans in
2022
and he has a website where you can
donate more money he pitches that next
there's only one way to contribute
to our efforts to elect america first
republican conservatives and in turn to
make america great again and that's
through
save america pac and donald j trump.com
so go out there and do whatever you can
because we're going to help a lot of
great people now based on his
grifting tens of millions of dollars
to quote fight the election results
which he just kept for himself
just months ago i'm skeptical that your
donations to this new grift
are really going to go to what he claims
they're going to go for and then as the
speech started winding down nearly 90
minutes after it started
donald trump teasing that he might run
in 2024.
with your help we will take back the
house
we will win the senate and then a
republican president
will make a triumphant return to the
white house
and i wonder who that will be
i wonder who that will be
who who who will that be i wonder
so yeah the important takeaways
trump has learned nothing he's still
repeating the same lies
the crowd still mostly loves it so maybe
it's the correct
lies to repeat i don't know he's uh
not yet committed to running in 2024
but he's not starting his own party and
he's
very willing to attack republicans who
don't
100 percent lay down for trump to walk
all over them
those are the takeaways and beyond that
the bit players during the entire cpac
weekend
mostly sucked up to donald trump or at
least avoided direct
criticism of donald trump so the overall
takeaway is
this remains the party of trump for the
time being
and mitt romney's statement last week
that the nomination is trump's if he
wants it in 2024 as
of today march 1st still holds true
things can change i still think that if
a lot of these trumpian
elected officials like bobert
marjorie taylor greene madison cawthorn
now accused by like 30 women of
harassment during college
if they go down in flames in 2022
it starts to change the picture for
trump in 2024 but we're getting ahead of
ourselves
after the break we'll look at a few
other key moments from cpac there
weren't that many
and we'll also have more coverage
coverage of this on the show's instagram
page
rapidly approaching 100 000 followers on
instagram
you can find us there at david pakman
show
one of our sponsors is sussman and han
sussman and han has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other supplies to stay safe during
covid19
and sussman and han is the company that
i've personally been going to
for face masks and other ppe because i
trust the products that they sell and
that's actually why we reached out to
them about becoming a sponsor because
their prices are reasonable ordering is
simple
everything ships within 24 hours and
they just have
high quality products for this global
hundred year pandemic they've got
surgical masks kn 95 masks
n95 masks other useful things like
infrared thermometers face shields
sanitizers
sussman and han is also an awesome
company because they've donated over 65
000 masks so far
to health care institutions shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can go to their website by
going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is right underneath this
video and they'll give you 20
off when you use the coupon code david